[Music]
we are here to destroy you
hello visitors from another planet
there's no need to fight anymore see
friends they took Lucy and the others
hang on you Franz plan
you mind if I save your life not at all
names Rex danger vest this is my [ __ ]
dinosaurs aliens kidnapped my friends
I'm going to get them back by an alien
queen I'm a queen whatever I would not
be the talking horse I could change my
fools if this makes you uncomfortable
hey guys they'll go back the horse was
much more palatable come with me on this
adventure to save my friends teach me to
be tough let's go find your friends on
your face literally a lantern how did
you miss me I love the holidays in
Apocalypse
the weather is dusty and the coffee
tastes extra pumpkin spicy this holiday
season has definitely descended into
chaos
now that the duplo savages destroyed our
land happy holidays sorry did I
interrupt your brooding sesh oh yeah
it's no biggie I was just filling
everyone in I'm half tough it is to live
here but you know it'll cheer everyone
up please miss a holiday party you said
it no yes No ah come on I've got a plan
step one get everyone together in the
town square step two ice skating step
three decorate this town for the most
tinsel tastic holiday party apocalypse
burg has ever seen
here hoobie captioning this holly-jolly
marry american
lower section 12 we need more green
bricks let's go let go loosen this tree
lights up you'll be able to see it from
we don't need any more unwanted
attention relax just think this is a
quiet little neighborhood shindig with
just a few of our closest friends in a
tree you may or may not be able to see
however you celebrate let's celebrate to
gather more eggnog huh hmm I wait all
year for this sweet nectar of joy
indubitably
my tummy is a little ruffly time to
light it up kid there she blows
I like darkness this isn't super
beautiful
[Music]
looks like a sauna paties apocalypse
burgers of visit yes
I mean oh no I knew it everyone fatal
stance I was not expecting that
[Music]
alfrid this sweater only has eight abs
now cool bro
[Music]
[Music]
okay let's address the elephant in them
all listen lady don't try any mind games
Batman is a permanent bat chiller can
you imagine if having a family with
someone I loved healed some of my
darkest drama birth there is no way I'm
marrying you I was just saying that to
make the person I actually want to marry
janeth good so I guess we're done here
or married at me
that's a good one you finally yeah and
uh out of curiosity why wouldn't you
want to marry me just you know again
purely for curiosity sake Oh Oh golfer
guys like you what do you mean guys I
mean it's so great were singing right on
time subject her to catchy pop music
this is a song that will get stuck
inside your head
[Music]
I've like heard at one time I'm not
gonna be singing that for the next two
weeks oh no are we in a musical I hate
musicals what I can't hear what you're
saying I'm too busy partying
[Music]
it's so catchy catchy my body is warming
I didn't know I do this
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
yeah tell you up everything is awesome
that song the Fox NFL Sunday stew you
not everything is Michael Strahan chair
minute you sit in Jimmie Johnson's
because you both had that helmet every
touchdown okay team welcome to Fox NFL
Sunday let's start football only those
her battle-tested will survive is
penultimate test that a week anyway
there are a trio of cubies vying to the
MVP of the league this year MVB most
valuable you cannot just make up your
own award why i think you guys need to
work this out on the field okay let's
break down a key play in today's game at
the or bo i'm eight feet away from you
just leave it no we've got football to
watch your man would have thrown it
right once everything was awesome now
okay Lucy I brought you coffee coffee
the bitter liquid that provides the only
semblance of pleasure left in these dark
times oh my gosh Ness
did I interrupt you brooding just now
times have changed
you need to change with them we have to
be tough and battle-ready
Oh
[Music]
hurry the door is slowly closing
oh the pain its gain so cold
see that wasn't so bad nothing got in
[Applause]
hang on your fronds planning we're going
[Music]
you mind if I save your life
not at all who are you danger cowboy
Raptor trainer I don't get it
we'll help me rescue my friends you
don't want to go anywhere near that
sistar system it's ruled by an alien
coin only the toughest you're gonna get
out of there alive I'm a queen whatever
I would not be I'm getting super evil
vibes here I could change my form to
something else if this makes you more
comfortable
hey guys they'll go back the horse was
much more palatable double dot on your
face
who are you I'm your worst nightmare
Oh me when I'm late to school and I
forgot my homework and my pants are made
of pudding no I don't you know this time
of year feels really great to get the
cast together and gather around the
microphone for the lego movie to the
second part I'm smiling so much my jaw
it's really hard to get back into the
lego universe it's the ultimate dream
job
everything was now everything is sweet
mayhem is coming after us and taking
different friends into the sistar system
[Music]
hang on to your fronds planning we're
going to save you
[Music]
it's really fun to be making something
that everybody will adore I change like
every five seconds I can change my form
for something else if this makes you
uncomfortable
you'll go back don't worry was much more
palatable a lifetime has passed since
the horrific events of Taco Tuesday our
lives send it into chaos this new life
has toughened and hardened
two copies please one black one with
just a touch of cream in 25 sugars Wow
stuff and last of us I wake up in the
morning morning good morning super
babies Emmett you've gotta stop
pretending everything is awesome it
isn't yeah I get it
and that's why I've cultivated a totally
hard-edged side that's super tough and
what is it up to but that beat is pretty
fresh
[Music]
[Music]
it's like it knows our every move weird
right special this guy was a fierce
warrior
okay well technically I did the warrior
sash so you fought a masterbuilt and hit
but and then the hapless male was the
leader he uh well
[Music]
hang on to your fronds planning we're
going to save Lucy and all of the other
people who were captured
[Music]
behold the sISTAR sister do not give her
the satisfaction of wooing this
[Music]